there seems to be basically two
strategies i see in industry now
one scares the heebie jeebies out of me
and the other one i find much more
encouraging
okay which one can we break them apart
which of the two
the one that scares the heebie-jeebies
out of me is this attitude that we're
just going to make ever bigger systems
that we still don't understand
until they can do be as smart as humans
i
what could possibly go wrong right yeah
i think it's just such a reckless thing
to do and unfortunately
and if we actually succeed as a species
to build artificial general intelligence
then we still have no clue how it works
i think at least 50 chance
we're going to be extinct before too
long it's just going to be an utter
epic own goal you know it's that 44
minutes
losing money problem or like the paper
clip problem like where
we don't understand how it works and
it's just in a matter of seconds runs
away in some kind of direction
that's going to be very problematic even
long before
you have to worry about the machines
themselves
somehow deciding to do things and to us
that we have to worry about people
using machines they're short of ai agin
power
to do bad things i mean just take a
moment
and if if anyone who's not worried
particularly about
advanced ai just take 10 seconds and
just think about your least
favorite leader on the planet right now
don't tell me who it is
you want to keep this apolitical but
just see the face in front of you that
person for 10 seconds yes now imagine
that that person has
this incredibly powerful ai under their
control
and can use it to impose their will on
the whole planet how does that make you
feel
you